I want to introduce our second speaker
who will be Paul
Maude which he was born a little bit
further away from here in a small town
called waitin in New Mexico in the
United States in 1946 he got his PhD at
Stanford University 1973 and he's now an
investigator at Howard Hughes Medical
Institute and he's also James Bijoux
professor at Duke University in Durham
North Carolina and with this I welcome
professor Madrid to the stage
so I want to thank the Royal Swedish
Academy for their acknowledgement of DNA
repair and for permitting me to share in
this wonderful honor so doctor Lindsay
said we've studied mismatch repair which
corrects base pairing errors in the DNA
helix and plays an important role in the
control of mutation production
inactivation of the human pathway
increases the mutation rate a hundred to
a thousand fold and the resulting
consequences can be pretty dramatic and
I'll cite several examples as I go along
whoops this is not working oh that's
fine
sorry so I thought it'd begin with a
little history the idea that mismatched
base pairs occur in cells was and that
such lesions triggered their own
processing was suggested 50 years ago by
Robin Holliday in the context of genetic
recombination breakage and joining of
DNA helixes was known to occur during
this process and Holliday pointed out
that the precision of rejoining could be
in short assured by formation of a
header a duplex joined a region of helix
in which the two strands are derived
from the different recombining partners
he also pointed out that if this header
a duplex should span a genetic
difference between the two DNA's it will
contain one or more mismatched base
pairs and he invoked processing of those
base pairs as the basis of the
recombination associated phenomenon
called gene conversion noting that if
there are enzymes which can repair
points of damage in DNA would seem
possible that the same enzymes could
recognize the abnormality of base
pairing and by exchange reactions
rectified this
direct evidence that mismatched base
pairs trigger a repair reaction was
provided by bacterial transformation
experiments and our interest in this
effect was prompted by the coli studies
done in that Nelson's lab Wagner and
using artificially constructed header
duplexes containing multiple mismatched
base pairs Wagner and meselson showed
that mismatches trigger a repair
reaction when introduced into the e coli
cell they also showed that closely
spaced mismatches mismatches separated
by a thousand base pairs or so are
usually repaired on the same DNA strand
and based on that strand bias effect
they suggested that in addition to its
role in genetic recombination mismatch
repair may act to correct mutations that
arises replication errors if so it may
be that mismatch repair acts in the
directed manner in conjunction with
sister chromatid exchange or that it
occurs with particularly particularly
high efficiency on newly synthesized DNA
strands possibly because of their under
make under methylation or because of a
special relation to the replication
complex this proved to be a particularly
insightful proposal we now know from the
work of many labs that correction of DNA
biosynthetic errors is a primary job of
mismatch repair and in order to function
in that manner the repair system has to
be able to do two things it has to
recognize the mismatch produced by the
replication error but I must also be
able to identify the new strand which
contains the mistake and Pat Pugh Kela
working in the meselson lab showed that
strand direction of e.coli mismatch
repair is dictated by the state of
adenine methylation at GATC sequences
because this modification occurs after
DNA synthesis newly synthesized DNA
exists in a transparent
modified form and it's to have this
transient absence of methylation that
directs mismatch repair to the new
strand and very Glickman mere admin and
others showed that this methyl directed
reaction depends on the products of for
mutator genes mutate you know me deaths
and UV rd inactivation of any of these
genes increases the mutation rate by in
in the coli cell by fifty to a hundred
fold indicating the importance of this
pathway and mutation avoidance in
genetic stability so this is where we
entered the picture I was interested in
how mismatches might be recognized how
the state of DNA methylation at one side
on the helix could direct mismatch
repair somewhere else and to address
those questions we needed a biochemical
assay so exploiting several tricks
developed in Norton's inder's lab Ollie
and Lou built header duplex DNA's like
the circular molecule and which the
strands were in defined states of DNA
methylation and which contained a gteen
this match and the recognition side for
eco r1 restriction enzyme this because
this mismatch blocks cleavage by eco r1
when this DNA is digested with eco r1
and bam h1 which cleaves down here the
product gives you a full-length linear
product which runs on an agarose gel
here but if repair occurs on the
unmethylated strand is predicted by the
meselson mechanism then this GT mismatch
will be converted to a GC base pair
restoring a quorum when sensitivity so
digestion with the two enzymes will
yield to smaller fragments that run down
here in fact incubation of this DNA with
extracts prepared from broken e.coli
cells converts it to an eco r1 sensitive
form and as predicted by the meselson
mechanism this reaction is blocked when
both DNA strands are methylated and the
extract reaction also depends on the
products of muta hmm you'd ask
you VRD which i mentioned a moment ago
are required for mismatch repair in the
bacterial cell
Michael su ba bla hue and the cure no
showed that this extract reaction
supports the repair of all the base base
mismatches except CC and that at least
one Hemi methylated GATC site is
required for repair to occur and that
latter observation prompted
simplification of our substrates and
molecules contain a mismatch in a single
GATC site that are separated by about a
thousand base pairs an ollie and lube
showed that this extract reaction is
accompanied by DNA synthesis occurring
on the unmethylated strand which
suggested that mismatch repair was
concurring by an excision repair
mechanism and working in collaboration
with Jack Griffiths lab at the
University of North Carolina Mike sue
and Michel Grilli confirmed this to be
the case
so when Hemi methylated in as incubated
with an e coli extract under conditions
a DNA synthesis block this results in
production of a single strand gap the
spans the shorter path between those two
DNA sites and this was true for both
Hemi methylated configurations of the
substrate because the two DNA strands
are anti-parallel this said that there's
no obligate polarity of the two DNA
strands and suggested that the methyl
directed system is capable of
bi-directional excision and I'll return
to that point in a moment well just try
and figure out how this reaction works
we isolated the mutation middle meatus
and UV Rd gene products we knew from the
work of Peter Emerson's lab that UV Rd
encodes an enzyme called DNA helicase -
that unwinds the helix and that ATP
dependent fashion but the nature of the
other three proteins was not known and
Michael su quickly showed that mute s is
responsible for mismatch recognition
a conclusion that's beautifully
confirmed in this crystal structure of a
muted dimer bound to a GT mismatch that
was solved in tisha six months lab
michelle Grilli showed that Moodle is
recruited to the Mutis mismatch complex
in an atp-dependent fashion but
otherwise essentially did not alter the
covalent nature of the DNA helix and
Kate Welsh and oli and Lou found that
the mutates gene product has a very
tightly associated but nearly dead and a
nucleus activity that in size is DNA at
an unmethylated GATC sequence and and
I'll tell you in a moment that Layton
endonuclease is activated by assembly of
this complex but these four proteins
were not sufficient
so using biochemical and genetic
approaches Karen oh and Bob Lee Hugh
used genetic and biochemical methods to
identify other required activities and
they identified for thence I'm called
exonuclease one which hydrolyze a
single-stranded DNA with three prime to
five prime polarity the single strand
DNA binding protein SSB DNA polymerase 3
holoenzyme which functions in chromosome
replication and DNA ligase
supplementation in mutation dome and s
and UV Rd or DNA helicase to where those
four proteins was sufficient to
reconstitute methyl directed repair in a
purified system and I'll tell you in a
second why sufficient here isn't quote
the essays shown here is a refined
version of the one I showed earlier in
this case the GT mismatches placed an
overlapping recognition sites for two
restriction enzymes it blocks cleavage
by both enzymes but when repair occurs
on the bottom strand the GT mismatch is
converted into an eighty base pair
yielding a good Hindi three site and
when repair occurs on the top strand the
mismatch is converted to a GC base pair
and a good xhr one side and this permits
repair to be directly scored on either
stand any
using that kind of a say hetero duplex
DNA that lacks a GATC site is not a
substrate for repairing this system nor
is a hetero duplex in which both strands
are methylated however Hemi methylated
DNA is repaired and when the methyl
group resides on the Strand containing
the mismatched G repairs exclusively to
GC and when the strand containing the
mismatched T is methylated repair is 280
in other words repair is methyl directed
now they mentioned a moment ago analysis
of the extract reaction suggested that
the methyl directed repair might have a
bi-directional excision capability which
presumably depend on both 5 prime to 3
Prime and three prime to 5 prime X and
nucleus activities then that proved to
be correct Dini Cooper Vickers were dead
and Celia baton jurors showed that when
the unmethylated strand was I the
unmethylated GATC site resides 5 prime
to the mismatch repair depends on a 5
prime to 3 prime X and depends on 503
from hydrolysis that can be mediated by
one of two X of nucleases xo7 or Rick J
and collaborative experiments who loved
its lab showed that when the GATC site
is located 3 prime to the mismatch
repair de vents on 3 to 5 excision by
exonuclease 1 or X in nucleus 10 our
original reconstituted system shown here
contained only one X in nucleus X in
nucleus one and the reason these
experiments were successful but because
the DNA polymerase 3 whole enzyme
preparations used in these experiments
where can't contaminated by EXO 7 so let
me tell you how this reaction works
mismatch recognition by mew deaths leads
to recruitment of mew Dell as I
mentioned and mew del served the
interphase mismatch recognition by new
tasks
the activation of several downstream
repair activities and one of those is
the latent mutates GTC endonuclease I
mentioned a moment ago Kirino showed
that methyl directed repair initiates by
activation of mutate and immunity in a
mismatch Mew - Mew del dependent fashion
incision by activated mute H is directed
to the unmethylated strand and can occur
either v prime or 3 prime to the
mismatch consistent with a
bi-directional mechanism and the
important point in the one I'll ask you
to keep in mind because I'll come back
to it in a moment is that it's the
resulting mutate strand break that is
the real signal that directs repair in
this system medicine noodle also
activates the excision system which is
comprised of DNA helicase to the UV Rd
gene product and the several single
strand acts and nuclease as I mentioned
a moment ago
Vivian Dao and Mookie on Iguchi showed
that mute s and Miguel load helicase to
at the mutate strand break so unwinding
proceeds back towards the mismatch and
this is true for both header duplex
orientation whether than strand break is
located five prime three prime for the
mismatch the single strand DNA segment
is displaced by helicase unwinding is
then degraded by one of these single
strand exonuclease I mentioned xo7 or
reck J when the break is 5 prime to the
mismatch or by XO 1 or XO 10 when the
break is 3 PI 2 the mismatch and the
resulting gap is then repaired by DNA
polymerase 3 holoenzyme and although not
shown here ligase finish this job by
restoring covalent continuity to the
helix so and I just want to mention one
thing so and on a passionate showed that
these function of these components of
the polymerase 3 whole ones I'm
absolutely restricted to the repair
since that's a step they have no
function in the muta activation or the
excision steps of the reaction and I
mentioned that in passing because the
human reaction
going to talk about surely differs in
that regard so this system clearly
involves action at a distance
coupled interaction of two DNA sites
that in our substrates are separated by
about a thousand base pairs but the
mechanism by which that occurs has been
a subject of debate for more than twenty
years
this orientation dependent loading of
helicase shown here implies that the
repair system can establish the relative
orientation of those two sites and that
requires that a signal be transferred
between those two sites along the helix
contour several labs including ours are
shown that mute s and probably the mute
LS complex is capable of moving along
the helix in an atp-dependent manner but
and we favor the idea that that sort of
movement is involved in this signaling
but that's not proven and because my
time is limited I'm going to leave it at
that so is our work on the muscle
directed reaction progressed we became
curious whether a similar strand
directed reaction might occur in higher
cells work from a number of labs had
shown that mismatches are rectified in
higher cells but there was no evidence
for strand directed repair and the
problem we had addressing this question
was we had no idea what the Strand
signals were Jude Holmes who began these
experiments circumvented that problem by
exploiting an observation we'd made in
the coli pathway namely that the purpose
of the Hemi methylated GATC sigh and
mute age is simply to provide a strand
break the strand break is the real
signal so Jude built header duplex DNA's
containing a site-specific strand
specific Nick and he showed that these
DNA's are subject to repair on the Nick
strand and extracts of broken human
cells very little repair occurs on the
continuous strand and when both strands
are covalently continuous repair is
blocked
and we weren't Fong showed that the DNA
hydrolytic events occurring on these
molecule is restricted to the shorter
path between the two DNA sites
regardless of their 5 prime to 3 Prime
orientation and this is reminiscent of
the bi-directional nature that you call
interaction I mentioned a moment ago but
as you will see the mechanism of human
reaction differs significantly so the
development that permitted us to
identify the key proteins involved in
initiation of human mismatch repair and
pursue the mechanism of the reaction was
the publication of two papers from the
de la chapelle vogelstein and Purusha
laboratories and these studies showed
that frequent mutation than simple DNA
repetitive sequences are characteristic
of tumors that appear in patients with
Lynch syndrome a common hereditary
cancer that accounts for about 5% of
colon cancers in the clinic as well as
about 15% of sporadic cancers with Lynch
like features and we knew from previous
work of Levinson and government that
these kinds of mutations are also
characteristic of E coli mismatch repair
mutants so it seemed plausible to us
that these tumor cells might be
defective in mismatch repair so we
acquired a number on should on one thing
I forgot to mention is Al what did I do
yeah I forgot to mention that's the the
this phenotype that is frequent
mutations in these simple repetitive
sequences called microsatellite
instability so we acquired a number of
tumor cell lines with microsatellite
instability initially from Bert
vogelstein and then from a number of
other labs and Goldman Lee we aren't
falling that long lean Jim Drummond
showed all of these cell lines to be
defective in the Strand directed
reaction I mentioned a moment ago an
availability of these repair defective
cells permitted us to isolate and
identify the proteins that are deficient
in these lines
Jim Drummond and gomen Lee showed that
several of these lines are deficient in
a protein we called mute as alpha a
heterodimer of two mute s homologs msh2
and ms eight six that we now know to be
the primary mismatch recognition
activity in human self and Gulman Lee
showed that the remaining lines were
defective in a protein we call me Adelle
off a heterodimer of two noodle homologs
mlh1 and PMS - while we were pursuing
these biochemical experiments several
ads primarily those of Bert vogelstein
and Richard Claude nur we're sequencing
Mutis and muta all homolog genes and
Lynch syndrome families and they showed
that mutations in these genes segregate
with the disease phenotype and is now
very clear that the vast majority of
excuse me cancers in linz families are
caused by inactivation of one of these
two heterodimers the last four cell
lines shown here proved to be
exceptional each was derived from a
microsatellite unstable sporadic cancer
each is defective in mismatch repair and
Jim Drummond showed that all four of
these cell lines failed to produce the
mlh1 subunit of Muta alpha and that
repair could be restored to extracts in
each of those cases by addition of
purified me Adele awesome but we
encountered some skepticism when we
shared these findings with our
sequencing colleagues who told us that
they'd sequence two mlh1 gene in this
line and this line and it was normal but
sandy Markowitz with whom we were
collaborating on the two vacant alliance
shown here it took us seriously and
collaborative experiments largely done
in his lab showed that the mlh1 gene in
these four cell lines is epigenetically
silenced by CPG methylation within the
promoter this blocks transcription mlh1
polypeptide is not produced resulting in
a mismatch repair defect and the proof
of that is shown here exposure of these
cell lines to
the cytosine which results in transient
cytosine demethylation results in
transient mlh1 expression it goes up and
then it comes back down and I mentioned
this effect because it's very important
in the clinics where it's believed to
account for about 15% of colon cancers
so I wanted to both remaining remaining
minutes telling you what we've learned
about how human mismatch repair works
the eight proteins shown here are
sufficient to reconstitute a minimal
system that supports bi-directional
human mismatch repair in a purified
system and I want to tell you about two
strand directed reactions that we've
identified that are supported by subsets
of these proteins the first of these
shown here is essentially in a sense a
trivial example of strand direction the
only EXA nuclease that has been
definitively implicated and eukaryotic
mismatch repair is an enzyme called
exonuclease one which hydrolyzes duplex
DNA with five prime to three prime
polarity Jochen gen she'll showed that
XO one is activated by Mutis alpha the
human mismatch recognition activity i
mentioned a moment ago in a mismatch
dependent manner and we think that
movement of muta self along the helix is
involved in coupling action of these two
sites activation by muta alpha renders
XO one highly precise --iv amp recessive
action of the Mutis alpha xl1 complex is
controlled by the RP a single binding
protein which displaces this complex
from the helix after removal of about
two hundred nucleotides this RP a filled
gap is an incredibly poor substrate for
XO one and the enzyme cannot reload
without the assistant mismatch dependent
assistance of Mutis alpha what this
means is that this iterative and I'm not
sure I mentioned it so excision by this
recessive complex when it's being
controlled by our pas restricted to
about two
nucleotides and as I said this gap our
PA field gaps incredibly poor substrate
for xo1 and it requires the assistance
of Mutis alpha mismatch dependent
assistance of muta self to reload so
what this means is that this iterative
cycle of removal about 200 nucleotides
will continue until the mismatch is gone
at which point excision is dramatically
attenuated because meatus al-faqih no
longer assist in this way this reaction
does not depend on the other mismatch
repair protein on that unit does not
require the other mismatch repair
protein I mentioned Udell alpha but
Moodle often does modestly enhance the
mismatch dependence of this effect the
second strand directed reaction that I
want to tell you about is more
interesting free Kadir off Liotta's ante
of and Nicoletta Constantin showed that
unlike bacterial Mew del human Mew del
alpha is a latent and a nuclease that's
activated in a manner that depends on
the mismatch Mutis alpha mismatch
recognition activity the PCNA
replication clamp and RFC the clamp
loader that places PCNA on the hillock
an action of this and a nucleases strand
directed it's targeted to the header
duplex strand that contains the
preexisting break incision by muta alpha
can occur at multiple sites along the
helix but initial events are biased to
the distal side of the mismatch freed
showed that this reaction occurs on both
five-prime and three-prime header and
duplex yield products molecules in which
the mismatch is bracketed by five-prime
and three-prime strand breaks and he
showed that v prime term and i produced
in this manner can serve as loading
sites for two modes of mismatch removal
hydrolytic removal by Mutis alpha
activated EXO one the reaction i
mentioned a moment ago or synthesis
driven strand displacement by DNA
polymerase delta and other potential
excision that's
mechanisms are possible as well so we
think that this and a nuclease function
of mu del alpha is is a primary function
of that protein and eukaryotic mismatch
repair and the reason I say that is
shown here
Freed's identified a metal binding and a
nuclease active site motif within the
PMS 2 subunit of mew del alpha this
motif shown in red here amino acid
substitutions within this motif have no
effect on assembly of the moodle alpha
munis alpha in a ternary complex but
they inactivate and a nucleus function
and they abolish from mismatch repair in
human yeast and mouse cells and in the
case of mice this is associated with
strong cancer predisposition I should
add that the yeast experiments shown
here we're done in collaboration with
Tom Coco's lab and the mouse experiments
with Winfrey David Lynch lab at Albert
Einstein so this red motif is under
nucleus motif is conserved and
eukaryotic PMS to homologs but it's also
found in many bacterial moodle's the
notable exceptions are Mew del proteins
from bacteria like e-coli and it's
cousins that rely on GATC methylation to
direct mismatch repair in those bacteria
this motif is conspicuously absent
though I'm this is my last experimental
sign so I want to say just a little bit
about what we've learned about
activation the mechanism of activation
of Mew del alpha on a pre shinnok and
Liotta's on T of showed that the only
function of the preexisting strand break
is to provide a loading site for the PC
and a clamp and that RFC involvement in
this reaction is restricted to loading
PCNA on the helix so PCNA mu less often
moodle alpha are the place
here and PCNA loaded PCNA does two
important things physical and active
interaction of PCNA with middle office
required to activate and a nuclease
function and the strand direction with
which PCA is loaded on the helix
determines the strand direction of in
the nuclease action and that's depicted
here in a schematic form the piece of
the two phases of PCNA clamp are not
equivalent the O'Donnell and Korean labs
have shown that PCA is loaded at three
prime double strand single strand
junctions with a unique orientation
that's depicted here with the gold face
is oriented towards a three prime end
we know from the work of Joe Jarek Nia
and Richard Claude nur that Mutis alpha
is tethered to the replication fork via
physical interaction with PCNA and we
know that both of these proteins can
move along the helix when Mutis alpha
recognizes a mismatch this leads to
recruitment and I think that pointer
they're the leads to a curtain of moodle
alpha which is capable of interaction
with both PCNA and Mutis alpha and the
idea is that the asymmetry of piece and
a loading is preserved in the PCM you
del alpha complex and this serves to
orient the and a nucleus active site
relative to the two strands of the helix
so when I began this discussion of
eukaryotic mismatch repair I mentioned
that we had no idea about the nature of
the strand signal but the those two
strand directed reactions that I've
described suggest several possibilities
in the context of the eukaryotic
replication fork which is shown here for
example five prime term and I on the
lagging strand would presumably support
voting of Mutis alpha activated EXO one
and genetic studies from Tom Coco's lab
is consistent with that view I also
mentioned that strand direction of you
know alpha and the nucleus action is
determined by the orientation with which
the PC and a clamp is loaded on the
helix
and at the fork that is determined by
three prime term and I on the leading
and lagging strand so an obvious
possibility is that Turman I that
naturally occur at the eukaryotic
replication fork may will serve as
default strand signal that direct
mismatch repair in the cell so that's
all I'm going to stop there I've
acknowledged the people that did the
work I've described some of them
returned to Duke for a recent party and
this is a complete list of my colleagues
and collaborators in this work one of
these collaborators is also a friend a Z
San char our next speaker thank you